okay
i think this is a good start
because i really want to get my knight
here if pawn captures my rook is brought
to life
that's enough reason for me to start
with that form
actually another one was to throw a
center pawn up there like this
behind this rook
all right let's follow through here
these four pawns are all covered by
these two guys
at least
i can already castle
this pawn is being hit
i don't want to do this because i weaken
e4
how about
well i don't want to do this either
because of bishop h3
just go one step
let my bishop defend this pawn
this might be a tricky line with g6
bishop takes pawn might be on
g6 bishop takes pawn bishop takes queen
takes b2 and how would i defend this
well i just moved the knight
and my rook is there to defend my bishop
i was thinking both of these minor
pieces would be
unprotected
um okay
next move
hmm
it's a bit uncomfortable
let's
that night's not going to bother me
anytime soon let's get him out
i think i just need to move this guy
in order to castle queenside i could
already castle kingside
i think i want to castle
queenside
not sure
bishop d2 i don't want to obstruct my
epon bishop d2 to c3 if g6 is played
i'll have trouble getting him out let me
go one step
queenside castle next
oh
hang on though
hmm
that's a bit annoying
to be honest
i'm gonna go one step
hang on
i still allow this push
how about hang on what about this
knight here throw a punch this
if i move my pawn i'm fearful of c5 and
i don't know how he gets working again
with this last move b5 is one of the
squares that have been weakened what
about knight d4
moving the same piece twice but at least
making sure my knight will remain active
they're connected i'm throwing a punch
here and now i think a4
might end up losing a pawn but
i'm gonna try it
um i'm going to try it c5 here bishop
takes pawn takes knight c7 i think i'll
have to live with that pawn
dropping
okay
i think i want to throw this pawn in the
center
like right now
let's go for it
yes definitely let's get e4 in
it's kind of weird
having the kings like this the rooks on
the rooks right next to the king
i'm really thinking about queen side
castling
especially if this default opens up if
we have d take c d takes e and this file
is completely open queenside castling
pretty nice
queenside castling for black
there's a lot of ponds that have moved
definitely have to go there
and now on knight c7 bishop takes pawn
takes knight c7 e5 will trap this bishop
so this is probably pretty uncomfortable
for black
threatening to take the bishop and mess
up the pawn structure
don't have another move then to
recapture so
remove that
save a half a second
and then
consider e5 i might want to just keep
this
this pond duo here
retain the flexibility
giving me that dark square bishop huh
also weakening light squares so this
comes to mind here
i like well you know if i take here
maybe this pawn is going to be captured
let me get this moving first
maybe i just play here
and then b3 make sure he's outside of my
pawn chain
okay and now
um
i'm gonna go with this
now if he isn't taken i'm going to take
the bishop and play b3
and
well we'll see how it pans out what's
this knight going to do i might want to
consider h3 and g4
and i'll certainly be going queen side
okay take here slight space advantage
he's glued here
on b5 my bishop stays very active they
went kingside
wow
this is fairly locked over here isn't it
i'm not going to commit just yet maybe
i'll still go side
maybe king side this is still a fine
structure if i want to go
king side you know nice little flight
square though my queen is kind of stuck
i don't know that i want to play here
being in a pin but
not really a way to exploit that
but i'm gonna reserve my options for
just a little bit still
leaving my options open not declaring my
king's intentions just yet two minutes a
minute and a half for team black
what
oh this pond wants to move
getting out of a pin
okay
i think i want to push in the center
with tempo and i'm going to do that
and i am going to follow up with
g4 next
your queen is stuck my queen has more
movement here
and this is probably
a big issue now
oh boy okay
take here
yeah i really like damaging th with this
structure this bishop is kind of dead
isn't he
knight here
my initial reaction was get my knight
into c4
but i should be thinking more forward
like knight g5 hitting here
yeah this has to be incredibly annoying
right now this move
i'm going to castle king side i'm not
even going to make it i'm not going to
allow it get to a point where there's
even some thought of a race
oh that's close to mate
that's the ball game here because he's
dropping
it's even worse than that i hit the rook
he has to go back and then he come
arrives back here now this time with the
fork
i'm going to be up a full piece there
a full rook i should say all right good
game let's back up here let me dive into
this
right here
game history
where was there
an issue
um i was starting to feel like i didn't
like my decision to start with f4
and i was liking your move
you know i i started to think that maybe
i should have started out similar to
how you did it with d5
because i think there was
going to be a better way you could
follow up
probably starting right here
you're supporting your center
but why i wonder
maybe one day you could get a little bit
more out of your pawn maybe he wants to
play two squares
maybe he has more options and you should
retain them
what about knight f6
that's maybe another one to consider
okay
at h6
trying to get into these squares
not so sure about that though
it's another pond move
a lot of pond maybe just way too many
pond moves here
and the night being sidelined this is uh
it's like
kind of you this is like a half
developing move
yeah he's off the back rank but beyond
that not doing too much i mean he's
serving the purpose of defending that
pawn too many pawn moves i think
if you are going to go with this light
square pawn structure maybe look to get
him out
maybe here
i like knight f6 here
knight f6 maybe to get your knight here
and yeah maybe where else is he gonna go
i mean well okay in the game he went
he went to c7
but maybe maybe again you could make it
you could do this move
maybe knight to b6
immediately not sure this is
tough
too many pond moves as it turned out in
this one
you're kind of giving me some
very valuable information if you're
doing these
advances because i'm pretty sure you're
not going to go in this direction
and i'm still i still have structures on
both sides of the board
that are
quite good for my king
you know they're
a group of two pawns still on their home
square a group of two
whereas this is really your only safe
side of the board
i don't know
and that gets kicked this is this feels
like it's big trouble now
started starting to become a bit
overwhelming here in the center having
this pond duo on two pawns on the fourth
rank here you have two pawns on the
fourth rank
but i also have a knight now in your
territory and he's a giant pest
i think this was the other try no i back
up i was saying it during the video
or during the game
bishop takes pawn takes knight c7 is met
with e5 and your bishop stuck
seems very awkward
there has to be a better setup and i'm
not quite sure what it is
maybe night out
hmm
it's tough call
night out maybe maybe this pawn push
get your knight to a better square i'm
not really sure what to even offer uh i
liked how you started but i don't know
how exactly to follow up really
i have to devote a lot more time than i
am right now to
coming up with something in these
original starting positions but
yeah
i don't know if you're i mean in the
game your knight ended up not making use
of any of these two squares so
probably better to keep it more central
knight f6 bishop to f5
um knight b6 i think you're kind of done
with pawn moves maybe making one more
pawn move
with e6 after he's out here somewhere
but
turned out to be too many pawn moves
this v6
trying to inconvenience my knight but
that really turned out to be a waste
because i centralized him and
then dropped into b5
so just a couple ideas i'm throwing at
you there
he turned out to be an awesome piece
and your king was lacking a lot of space
here
it's just too much even if you're
defending here when the best move is
queen here it's the only way to defend
this pond is still very difficult
because this is happening and your king
is in trouble
but okay that's fisher random for you
alrighty
uh good game let's uh close out of this
you